lange kontaktsperre die nächsten drei
wochen werden die antivirus maßnahmen in
deutschland nicht gelockert sagt das
kanzleramt corona im altersheim in
wolfsburg sterben zwölf bewohner immer
mehr heime haben große probleme und
epizentrum usa das virus breitet sich
rasend schnell aus vor allem in
metropolen wie new york und new orleans
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend hinein und
herzlich willkommen auch heute an diesem
samstag geben sie uns knapp 20 minuten
und wir geben ihnen den überblick über
die nachrichtenlage und natürlich
zunächst die aktuelle situation im kampf
gegen das virus
wir brauchen geduld viel geduld das ist
jetzt bereits klar jeder der die regeln
befolgt kann ein lebensretter sein sagt
die bundeskanzlerin und sie weist alle
zurück die jetzt fordern die
einschränkungen für das leben in
deutschland müssten schnell aufgehoben
werden der kanzleramtschef nennt dazu
heute ein datum helge braun sagt bis zum
zwanzigsten april reden wir nicht über
irgendwelche erleichterungen christoph
festival jetzt mit einem überblick
flughafen köln bonn kurz nach mittag
andere fliegen nicht mehr zur sicherheit
aber dieser flug aus bergamo könnte
leben retten sechs an der zahl
die sechs italiener aus dem
katastrophengebiet alle müssen beatmet
werden jetzt in deutschland gleich
mehrere solcher hilfsaktion laufen
gerade am späten nachmittag dann zwei
der eingeflogene patienten kommen in
eine bochumer klinik vorerst ist dort
noch platz für coop 19 patienten
illusionen macht sich hier aber keiner
dass wir auch in unsere grenzen stoßen
werden das wissen wir
daraufhin hat sind wir vorbereitet und
der personal weiß dass wir wissen dass
rund 15.000 intensivbetten kann
deutschland für corona stemmen viele
sind im moment noch frei nur deshalb
können wir anderen ländern helfen bis
man das hängt auch von der kraft der
pflege und schwestern haben auf der
seite wo die patientin dingen sehr
anstrengend weil man sehr viel
schutzkittel und wenn man in seinem
zimmer ist und auch eine gute pflege
versorgung gemacht es war nass
durchgeschwitzt weiter also oberstes
gebot kontakt vermeiden gerade mal eine
woche mit den neuen regeln ist geschafft
seit heute ist klar
mindestens drei kommen noch dazu wir
reden jetzt bis zum zwanzigsten april
nicht über irgendwelche erleichterungen
bis dahin bleiben alle maßnahmen
bestehen läden restaurants schulen und
die universitäten sind geschlossen
rechtzeitig vor dem 20
wenn wir vor wie es in der phase danach
weitergeht abhängig von der ansteckung
skore stand heute 18 30 steigt sie
weiter 53 1340 infizierte in deutschland
399 tote aber drin bleiben bei der sonne
im hamburger volkspark etwa zeigte sich
wie schwer das ist fast eng wurde es
dort aber insgesamt hier beispiel
dresden scheinen die meisten verstanden
zu haben
zur erleichterung der kanzlerin aus der
quarantäne schickte sie grüße
wenn ich heute sehe wie fast alle ihr
verhalten völlig umgestellt haben wie
die große mehrheit von ihnen wirklich
jeden unnötigen kontakt vermeidet eben
weil er auch ein ansteckungsrisiko
enthalten kann dann möchte ich einfach
sagen danke von ganzem herzen danke auch
wenn manchmal die polizei sanft
nachhelfen muss gucken wir mal kurz
hinter die kulissen der politik mit theo
koll in berlin trugen amt wie viel
ungeduld macht sich denn bereits jetzt
in der politik breit wie viel kann man
da spüren
der unmut ist noch verhalten aber erst
da wird viel stimmiger die
fdp-opposition beispielsweise bemängelt
dass es keine exit strategie gibt also
einen plan wie und wann die derzeitige
kontaktsperre beendet werden soll und
der thüringische vorsitzende der
innenministerkonferenz spd fordert schon
in ein bis zwei wochen zu beurteilen wie
wirksam die maßnahmen sind die
gesellschaft käme sonst sagte ans limit
die sorgen der kritiker drehen sich
natürlich sowohl um die wirtschaftlichen
folgen jede fünfte firma sieht sich akut
von insolvenz bedroht als auch um die
psychologische belastung für die
bevölkerung
schon jetzt sprechen ja berichte von
einem steigenden risiko häuslicher
gewalt die kanzlerin hatte anfangs jahr
von mindestens zwei wochen kontaktsperre
gesprochen ihr kanzleramtsminister
spricht heute schon von mindestens vier
wochen das würde übrigens für einige
bundesländer bedeuten länger als die
dortigen osterferien
diese zeitliche salami strategie dürfte
mit jeder woche absehbar stärker in die
kritik geraten und dann braucht es eine
klare ansage wie es jenseits der
allgemeinen kontaktsperre weiter gehen
soll
die situation in der politik de
herzlichen dank dafür nach berlin und
dann gucken wir jetzt live ans rheinufer
in mainz zu bobby cherry an bobby noch
drei wochen mit einschränkungen
mindestens das hören wir heute wie sind
denn diese aussichten bei den menschen
angekommen
tatsächlich haben viele menschen mit
denen ich heute geredet habe damit
gerechnet dass die maßnahmen zur kontakt
beschränkungen mindestens bis zum
zwanzigsten april aufrechterhalten
werden und die meisten leute haben recht
unaufgeregt und gelassen reagiert hier
am mainzer rheinufer war auf jeden fall
heute eine menge los es waren sehr viele
menschen unterwegs meist aber eben nur
zu zweit oder als familie und mit
sicherheitsabstand so wie es zurzeit
sein sollte
das ist die eine seite die andere seite
das mainzer ordnungsamt ist nach eigenen
angaben heute permanent alarmiert worden
weil es sich irgendwelche
menschengruppen in parks oder auf
spielplätzen eingefunden haben kam das
ordnungsamt dann an haben sich dann
diese gruppen wohl im vorfeld schon
aufgelöst es war also gewissermaßen ein
katz und maus spiel also auf der einen
seite viel umsicht und einsicht und auf
der anderen seite ein gewisser grad an
trotz vielleicht sorglosigkeit an diesem
frühlingstag in mainz blaue stunde
gemeinsam rein bobby herzlichen dank die
situation bei unseren nachbarn in europa
ist zum teil dramatisch inzwischen
meldet italien mehr als 10.000 tote und
auch in großbritannien steigt die zahl
der opfer immer weiter an und in spanien
sterben 8 132 menschen innerhalb eines
tages so viele wie noch nie dort zwei
wochen nach beginn der ausgangssperre
ist die regierung in madrid trotzdem
vorsichtig optimistisch auch wenn die
zahl der neuinfektionen noch steigt auf
inzwischen mehr als 72.000 jetzt soll
auch das militär verstärkt eingesetzt
werden beim desinfizieren von heimen
gefängnissen und bahnhöfen aber auch
beim transport von toten
und in frankreich gibt es in zwei
regionen ganz besonders viele probleme
in der grenzregion im osten und im
großraum paris die kliniken arbeiten
dort am limit und rufen selbst um hilfe
die kommt auch über grenzen hinweg
französische patienten werden zur
behandlung nach deutschland geflogen
christel haas das französische militär
im einsatz gegen korona in metz werden
zwei schwer kranke patienten vorsichtig
in den hubschrauber gehoben sie werden
ins deutsche essen gebracht um die
krankenhäuser im grund es zu entlasten
auch im großraum paris herrscht
medizinischer notstand es gibt nicht
genügend betten heute nach zum beispiel
sind wird der patienten auf die
intensivstation gekommen wir mussten
auch welche ablehnen oder wieder mal für
die depression der premierminister
warnte in einer video pressekonferenz es
wird noch schlimmer
moko berne figge comeback kampf beginnt
erst jetzt die ersten 15 tage im april
werden noch schwieriger sein als die
vergangenen 15 tage in physik
archivieren
in einer turnhalle nahe paris haben
freiwillige eine behelfs notaufnahme
eingerichtet patienten mit symptomen
werden hier untersucht und notfalls
behandelt und isoliert sie wolle nicht
da sitzen und däumchen drehen sagt die
bürgermeisterin des ortes
seitdem wir dieses zentrum eingerichtet
haben haben wir unglaublich viel
unterstützung aus der ganzen region
bekommen sie sagen ich will nicht zu
hause bleiben
ich bin pensionierter arzt ich bin
medizinstudent ich möchte helfen
paris erwartet an diesem wochenende den
höhepunkt der pandemie am tag 12 der
ausgangssperre wirkt die stadt verweist
und unwirklich still
die metro fast menschenleeren
die uferpromenade ist gesperrt immer
wieder muss die wasserpolizei bewohner
zu recht weisen die sich trotz verbots
am fluss aufhalten
bleiben sie zu hause steht jeden abend
in großen lettern auf dem eiffelturm ein
fast flehentlich abwenden
das corona virus greift alle an für
ältere menschen ist es besonders
gefährlich umso größer also die gefahr
wenn es eine infektion in einem
seniorenwohnheim gibt und in wolfsburg
ist genau das passiert
zwölf menschen sind dort seit anfang der
woche gestorben allein gestern gab es
acht tote
niedersachsens ministerpräsident stephan
weil rief erneut alle bürger zur
vorsicht auf die situation in wolfsburg
zeige die unerbittlichkeit dieses virus
beginnen zu wollen
in wolfsburg malen guten abend weiß man
denn schon wie das jetzt dazu kommen
konnte
wer hinter mir ist das handliche
pflegeheim hier wohnen 165 menschen 72
haben sich bereits mit dem corona virus
infiziert das ist ja fast schon die
hälfte und das 12 innerhalb von einer
woche gestorben sind
diese schnelligkeit das hat hier alle
sehr überrascht darauf gibt es auch noch
keine klare antwort wie das passieren
konnte
man hat das personal gefragt
hygienestandards wurden eingehalten
masken getragen kittel getragen
es gibt hier vorwiegend demenzkranke die
konnten sich nicht an das kontaktverbot
halten und man vermutet dass unter ihnen
sich das virus verbreitet hat weil sie
auch diese dimension gar nicht fassen
konnten
wir versuchen denn jetzt die die pfleger
vor ort mit der situation klarzukommen
die pfleger versuche sie haben eine
strategie aber ich erzähle erst mal
chronologisch also die stadt wolfsburg
wollte erst noch heute alles evakuieren
das ganze heim
man hatte sich schon ein hotel
rausgesucht doch im letzten moment hat
die heimleitung zusammen mit dem
oberbürgermeister entschieden nein wir
bleiben jetzt alle hier das liegt daran
dass die meisten bewohner hier
demenzkranke sind und die hieraus ihrer
häuslichen umgebung rauszureißen das
würde ihren gesundheitlichen zustand
rapide verschlechtert also man hat sich
jetzt aber die strategie entschieden
im heim die gesunden und kranken zu
trennen ist wird sich zeigen in den
nächsten tagen ob das die richtige
strategie ist besonders tragisch
es gilt ein betretungsverbot in diesem
heim die angehörigen die konnten sich
nicht mehr von den verstorbenen
verabschieden wollen die laue in
wolfsburg dankeschön vor einer lage wie
in wolfsburg haben auch andere
pflegeheime angst natürlich
patientenschützer schlagen jetzt alarm
weil viel fehlt gerade atemschutz masken
und schutzkleidung in vielen heimen
steige die zahl der infizierten bei
pflegebedürftigen und auch bei denen die
sie pflegen katrina war in einem heim in
eggersdorf in brandenburg die 90 jährige
marianne schmidt kann fast nichts mehr
alleine machen sie braucht intensive
betreuung für die monika altenpflege hat
viel mit nähe zu tun gerade jetzt ist
mundschutz wichtig durch die bestände
des altenpflegeheims in eggersdorf gehen
zur neige
ich hoffe dass wir eine lieferung
kriegen das eigentlich ja dass wir
wieder durchatmen können ruhig schlafen
können und wissen wenn der fall ist
können wir aber auch jeden einzelnen
schützen
das hoffe ich dass wir einfach weiter
machen können weil die bewohner haben
uns und wir brauchen uns jetzt
sie brauchen nicht nur mundschutz auch
desinfektionsmittel handschuhe und
kittel brandenburg steht nach
einschätzung der wohlfahrtsverbände vor
der schließung soziale einrichtungen
weil es an nachschub fehlt
die leute müssen gepflegt werden die
angehörigen haben können zugang oder
können das nicht bewerkstelligen das
heißt ein wirklicher rückzug
es ist kaum möglich ist medizinisch
nicht vertretbar und wenn in der
konsequenz wir uns zurückziehen dann
heißt das oftmals dass die leute dann in
die krankenhäuser müssen brandenburg hat
heute vom bund eine große lieferung
atemschutzmasken bekommen die an einem
geheimen ort bewacht und
schnellstmöglich verteilt werden das
reichte aber nicht aus alles wird in
unserem krisenstab in der abteilung
beschaffung sofort geprüft und wenn es
sich um ein halbwegs seriöses angebot
handelt dann schlagen wir auch zu aber
die situation auf dem weltmarkt deshalb
sehr angespannt in eggersdorf gibt es
für stefanie bünker und ihre kollegen
eine spende selbst genähter mundschutz
60 stück doch das löst das problem bei
weitem nicht diese entwicklung ließ
aufhorchen großkonzerne wie adidas oder
deutschlands größter schuhhändler
deichmann außerdem h&m und andere
handelsketten zahlen erst mal keine
miete mehr für ihre filialen in
deutschland
bundesjustizministerin christine
lambrecht hat dafür kein verständnis
zitat wenn jetzt finanzstarke
unternehmen einfach ihre miete nicht
mehr zahlen ist dies unanständig und
nicht akzeptabel
die korona hilfs gesetze der regierung
würden dafür keine grundlage bieten sagt
die ministerin
mieter müssten miete zahlen ihnen dürfe
lediglich für einen begrenzten zeitraum
nicht gekündigt werden
so jetzt müssen wir noch auf ein neues
epizentrum dieser virus krise schauen
die usa sind mittlerweile das land mit
den meisten corona fällen mehr als
105.000 bestätigte infektionen und mehr
als 1700 tote die lage in den metropolen
verschlimmert sich schnell new york city
vor allem aber auch städte wie new
orleans werden jetzt zu hotspots der
krise der präsident aktiviert ein
wirtschafts gesetz das eigentlich für
kriegszeiten gedacht ist er will so den
nachschub an beatmungsgeräten sichern
aus den usa el mati wissen hier pulsiert
sonst das herz von new orleans jetzt
wird die jazzmetropole amerikas neues
epizentrum wohl weil sie mal die
gefeiert haben mit hunderttausenden von
touristen aus aller welt
einige brachten das virus mit in den
karneval ende februar die menschen
teilten sich ihre trinkgläser sie warfen
perlenketten von den wagen aber statt
perlen fingen die leute das corona virus
mitten zwischen einer million menschen
auf einem wagen der bekannte dj oliver
stoxx zwei wochen danach kamen die
symptome am 19
märz starb seine frau durfte nicht bei
ihm sein
ich konnte ihm nichts sagen dass ich ihn
liebe das war das schlechteste für mich
dass ich nicht bei ihm sein konnte
in lousiana gibt es bald 3000 positiv
getestete fast 800 tote
die zahlen steigen schneller als in
italien der gouverneur fordert strikte
einhaltung der ausgangssperre
ich akzeptiere nicht dass wir italien
werden so weit sind wir noch nicht aber
es klappt nur wenn wir die kurve
abflachen
in washington hat der präsident das
hilfspaket des kongresses unterschrieben
ohne die regeln des social dating selbst
vorzuleben erstmals macht er nun auch
gebrauch von einem gesetz für krisen und
kriegsfeld trump heißt autohersteller
general motors und firmen aus dem
gesundheitssektor an möglichst schnell
möglichst viele beatmungsgeräte zu
produzieren
wir werden nicht zögern die volle macht
der regierung zu nutzen um die krise zu
bekämpfen aber mit seinem wunsch dass
sich die lage bis ostern wieder
normalisiert sendet trump weiter
gemischte signale eine kirchengemeinde
in baton rouge louisiana hält sich nicht
an das versammlungsverbot während sie im
nahegelegenen new orleans die lehre von
mardi gras beherzigen und ganz anders
das bild in china offiziell gibt es kaum
noch neuinfektionen zeit für einen
symbolträchtigen schritt wohin also die
stadt in der die pandemie angefangen
hatte ist nicht mehr abgeriegelt nach
zwei monaten isolation dürfen wieder
menschen nach johann einreisen die
ersten züge waren voll mit bewohnern
angehörigen und arbeitern die wegen der
sperre nicht hatten zurückkehren können
die ausreise aus der elf millionen stadt
bleibt allerdings bis zum 8 april
verboten
auch bleiben die meisten geschäfte erst
einmal geschlossen
wer öffentliche verkehrsmittel nutzen
will muss auf einen gesundheitskurs ein
gesundheits code installiert haben auf
dem handy und eine maske tragen
mehr zu diesem thema gibt es gleich in
einem zdf spezial direkt nach und corona
krise wie die maßnahmen wirken und immer
auf dem laufenden bleiben sie natürlich
auch heute online
mit unserem live blog in der zdf- heute-
app die zeit vergeht in einem anderen
tempo in diesen zeiten so scheint es
zumindest fielen aber eines bleibt
gleich wir müssen die uhren umstellen
die eu kommission wollte das alles ja
eigentlich bis nächstes jahr abschaffen
aber irgendwie werden sich die länder
nicht einig welche zeit künftig die
richtige sein soll
jetzt beginnt also wieder die sommerzeit
um 2 uhr heute nacht wird die uhr eine
stunde weiter gedreht auf drei ende
oktober machen wir all das dann in die
andere richtung und mal sehen ob wir
morgen merken dass uns eine stunde
schlaf fehlt jetzt noch das liebe in
zeiten von corona kann schwer sein macht
erfinderisch inga lebt in dänemark
carsten in deutschland beide sind weit
über 80 ein deutsch dänisches liebespaar
mit einem noch vor kurzem undenkbaren
problem die grenze zwischen den beiden
nachbarländern ist dicht besuchen geht
nicht mehr
aber wer liebt will sich trotzdem sehen
also treffen sich die beiden auf abstand
mit wein und tageszeitung jeden tag am
gesperrten grenzübergang liebe kennt
keine grenzen und sie haben die jacken
gesehen die beiden sind schon mal gut
vorbereitet ab morgen ist erstmal
schluss mit sonne beim wetter deutlich
kühlere luft und sogar schnee sind
unterwegs die details hat es denn terry
der kollege claus kleber hat mehr für
sie um 22 uhr 45 im heute-journal morgen
freuen wir uns wieder auf sie punkt 7
für heute wo immer es geht machen sie
sich einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
ein guter abend und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter deutlich kältere luft
erreicht uns aus dem norden vom
polarkreis über skandinavien und das
wird schon in der kommenden nacht der
fall sein und die kalte luft hält sich
bis in die kommende woche
wir schauen in die nachts da gibt es
schon viele wolken im norden die gehören
zu dieser kaltfront die allmählich
südwärts zieht dazu wird der wind
kräftig werden kommt teils aus
nordöstlichen richtungen teils mit
sturmböen in der mitte ist es noch
locker bewölkt ganz im süden da gibt es
ebenfalls regen und schnee bei
temperaturen von minus ein grad im
vogtland und 5 grad im südwesten
deutschlands morgen dann kommt die
kaltfront bis zur mitte etwa voran dabei
regen und schnee teilweise bis ins
flachland ja und eine schneeschicht
bildet sich in den mittelgebirgen aus
auch im süden gibt es regen und schnee
in den höheren lagen die
schneefallgrenze sinkt allmählich und
dieser schneefall dauert bis montag an
an der nordsee und ostsee kann es
durchaus auch eine sturmflut geben und
das bei temperaturen von 4 grad im
vogtland und 11 grad im südosten die
nächsten tage am montag noch ungemütlich
mit regen und schnee aber allmähliche
auflockerungen bei minus 19 grad und
danach sonniger und ruhiger ein schöner
abend